once you throw  forwards try to pause for about two or  three seconds before you fall back  position as far  so when you're doing the movements it's  really important to coordinate  the upper and lower body together  and ideally you want your feet on the  ball a nice good alignment through the  body  sitting on the ground you're not letting  the lower back descent  and from here you would roll the ball  towards you  and then push back out maintaining good  posture  all the way through so the dorsal rays  you would curve around the ball have the  hands and arms alongside you  make a right fist and the thumbs are  sticking into also hips  as you uncurl you turn your thumbs out  and around and just squeeze your  shoulder blades  and then your turn  that's the next two exercises  so it's all about the alignment  managers  so  so  you